From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
[ Silencio ]
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon.
My name is Georgette Dorn and I'm
the Chief of the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress.
And I want to thanks Catalina Gómez
for having organize
this wonderful event.
Is the number six in our series
of Hispanic Heritage
[fonéticamente] Event;
the fourteen Hispanic
Heritage Event,
more than we've never have before.
And it's a great pleasure to
welcome here Gerardo Piña-Rosales,
the Director of the North American
Academy of the Spanish Language.
He's the author of many many
books, of which we have 10
in the Library of Congress.
I would ask you to please
turn off your telephones,
so we can hear everything
without interruption.
And when you ask questions
after-- Please give your name,
because you have been
filmed by the Library
for saving casting the
event on the web page.
And now I'd like to introduce Luis
Alberto Ambroggio who is going
to give an introduction
to Gerardo Piña-Rosales.
[ Silencio ]
>> Luis Alberto Ambroggio: I may
switch to Spanish, but anyway,
thank you Georgette, and thank
you to the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress, that
has done so much for our culture,
our literature, our presence here,
not only in the Library,
but in the US.
And it's for me a pleasure to be
here celebrating the month of the--
El Mes de la Hispanidad y los 500
Años de Literatura Hispana en
Estados Unidos.
Es un honor para mí presentar
al autor de la obra que vamos a
disfrutar, al Director de la
Academia Norteamericana en Lengua
Española, doctor Piña-Rosales,
aunque en las primeras páginas de
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias",
su propia versión autobiográfica
es mucho más divertida de lo que es
la mía, así que-- [ríe].
Nació en la línea de la
Concepción, en Cádiz, España.
Residió en Tánger, Marruecos
desde 1956 hasta 1973,
donde según él mismo,
se arrojó, y cito:
"Con el ímpetu y la osadía
propia de la adolescencia,
en brazos de la musa literaria".
Allí cursó estudios superiores
en el Instituto Español,
luego en las universidades
de Granada y Salamanca.
Emigró a los Estados
Unidos en 1973,
residiendo en New York
desde entonces.
¿Todos entendemos
español aquí o-- ?
No.
>> Hi. If you could speak slower--
>> Georgette Dorn: You
need an interpreter.
>> Luis Alberto Ambroggio: [Ríe].
I could say it in English, too.
But I don't know-- I think most
of the actual conversation--
And Dr. Gerardo Piña-Rosales
would be in Spanish
and the book is written in Spanish.
>> That's why I was [inaudible].
I can't speak that fast.
>> Luis Alberto Ambroggio: ¡Oh!
Ok. Entonces, se graduó en la
universidad de la ciudad de New
York, CUNY, donde luego en su
Centro de Estudios Graduados,
obtuvo un Doctorado en Lengua
y Literatura Españolas,
con una te riso sobre la literatura
del exilio español, en 1939.
Desde 1981, se desempeña como
profesor de literatura en CUNY,
el Aiman [fonéticamente] College,
el Centro de Estudios Graduados
y en otras instituciones
universitarias norteamericanas.
Miembro de la Academia
Norteamericana de la Lengua,
desde el primer, el
primero de abril de 1992,
cuando tomó posesión
con el discurso titulado,
y es importante dentro del contexto
de este libro, el discurso se titula
"El cuento: Anatomía de
un género literario".
Especialista en esta escritura,
Director de la Academia
desde el 2008,
anteriormente fue Secretario
y Coordinador de Información.
También es miembro correspondiente
de la Real Academia Española,
la RAE, miembro electo de la
Academia de Buenas Letras de
Granada, España, y Presidente
Honorario de la Sociedad Honoraria
Hispánica Sigma Delta
Pi, de Estados Unidos.
Son numerosos sus libros como autor,
como coautor, editor y coeditor.
El más reciente, por ejemplo,
"Los académicos cuentan",
anterior a eso, "El español
en los Estados Unidos",
¿"E Pluribus Unum?",
"Enfoques multidisciplinarios",
es un libro escrito
en colaboración.
También un libro que publica
la Academia en colaboración,
pero él lo edita, "Gabriela
Mistral y los Estados Unidos" y
podría seguir.
Tiene novelas y otros libros,
a su vez de él propio.
Son muchos, así que
voy a evitar esa parte.
Sería incompleta esta semblanza,
sin destacar otro aspecto muy
importante de su vida artística,
y es una afición por
la fotografía,
que incluso la pueden apreciar
en este libro y en libros que ha
editado la Academia de
la Lengua Española.
Fotografías que no solo
dialogan con la escritura en sus
publicaciones y las de otros que
nos beneficiamos de esta riqueza
ecfrástica, si no que logran una
visión artística por sí mismas.
Para finalizar, les robo sus
rebeldes y convocantes palabras en
el inicio de "El Secreto de
Artemisia y Otras Historias" y cito:
"¿Qué?
¿Cómo he tenido el atrevimiento,
la desfachatez de publicar ahora
estas descabelladas y hasta
aberrantes historias?
Pues muy sencillo, por perdonable
prurito de responsabilidad social y
más que nada por una irreducible
voluntad mía de testimoniar desde
este arcádico rincón rocanlés
[fonéticamente] y al margen de los
gatuperios literarios tan en boga,
mi logo esteparia oposición
frente a las condiciones,
valores y mitos de nuestra época.
Lo cortés no quita lo valiente".
Así, muchas gracias y con
ustedes, Gerardo Piña-Rosales.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Gerardo Piña-Rosales:
Muchísimas gracias,
Luis Alberto y muchísimas
gracias por estar aquí hoy para la
presentación de este
libro aquí en Washington.
Tengo que agradecer, por
supuesto, como siempre, ¿no?,
a Georgette Dorn, que es la
Jefa Directora de la División
Hispánica, el que
siempre nos acoja, ¿no?,
de manera tan generosa, que nos
abra siempre las puertas de esta
Biblioteca del Congreso.
Ella, por supuesto,
también es miembro de la
Academia Norteamericana.
Veo aquí a algunos,
¿no?, por ejemplo,
está con nosotros también
Javier Bustamante, de Baltimore,
que es también miembro de
la Academia Norteamericana.
Por supuesto, los que van a
hablar hoy, Carlos Pal dio,
que es el director de la revista,
quizás la mejor revista que existe
literaria en Estados Unidos, ¿no?,
en lengua española,
de Carlos Paldao.
Carmen Vessels-- También
con nosotros, ¿no?
Y por supuesto, ya han
oído a Luis Alberto.
Tenemos también aquí dos personas
que son miembros también de la
Academia, Isabel Campoy y Alma Flor
Ada, que residen en California,
pero que en esta hemos
tenido la suerte, ¿no?,
de coincidir esta mañana.
Y por supuesto, gracias a
todos por acompañarnos.
En fin, el libro tiene-- Es
curioso porque la portada,
ahí aparece una figura.
Y la gente dice Artemisia, bueno
pues esta es Artemisia, ¿no?
Pues yo no sé quién será,
¿pero tú lo reconoces?
¿La reconoces?
Sí, esta es la Biblioteca del
Congreso, es una fuente que hay,
sí, el edificio Jefferson,
ahí justo.
Una de las veces que vine.
>> Georgette Dorn:
La fuente de Neptuno.
>> Gerardo Piña-Rosales: Sí, creo
que sí, hay dos figuras, ¿no?
Entonces, esta figura--
Así que mandé,
a la editorial mandé un par de
ideas y ellos prefirieron esta,
¿no?
Así que ya se rebautiza
como Artemisia, ¿no?
En fin. Como decía, el libro
está dividido en varias secciones,
hay algunos relatos muy
breves, algunos inéditos,
otros éditos [fonéticamente],
¿no?
Una primera parte es un poco
autobiográfica y recuerda de una
manera onírica, si quieren,
¿no?, son sueños realmente,
recuerdos de Granada, donde viví
pues desde el año 68 al 71.
Y después he vuelto
mucho por Granada, ¿no?
La primera parte, ya digo,
autobiográfica y aparecen también
recuerdos de una ciudad que es parte
de mi identidad, ¿no?, que es
Tánger; sobre todo la ciudad,
pero también el país mismo,
¿no?, que es Marruecos.
Me he sentido siempre,
no identificado,
pero sí me ha interesado muchísimo
el mundo islámico en ese sentido,
ya que creo que parte de mi
identidad pues está también ahí,
¿verdad?, en esos recuerdos.
Me acuerdo que llegamos
a Marruecos en el 55, 56,
que es cuando Marruecos consiguió
la independencia, ¿verdad?
Yo recuerdo todavía los
tanques en la calle, en fin,
porque venía el rey, el rey
Mohamed V, que estaba en Madagascar,
lo habían exiliado, digamos,
los franceses a Madagascar.
Y el rey llegó, yo recuerdo
haber visto al rey pasar, claro,
verlo desde los hombros
de mi padre, no.
Era pequeñito, pero yo
quería ver al rey, ¿no?
En fin. Todos estos recuerdos de
la infancia, primera, adolescencia,
primera juventud y después también
hay un relato que realmente comenzó
con una, con una entrevista o
varias entrevistas a un autor,
al cual yo admiro muchísimo, que es
Paul Bowles, ¿verdad?, Paul Bowles.
Paul Bowles, es curioso, porque
cuando yo vivía en Tánger, bueno,
sabía quién era y lo había
visto en varias ocasiones,
pero ya hablar con él, fue ir
a su casa a entrevistarlo y tal,
eso fue después.
Paul Bowles es un hombre que
llegó a Marruecos en los años 30,
salió muy jovencito de
aquí, era de New York,
estuvo primero en París, muy joven
y Gertrudis Stein fue la que le
dijo, Paul, go to Marruecos, y es
curioso, porque llega a Marruecos.
No sé si llegó primero solo o
llegó con su compañero entonces,
que era Aaron Copland, el gran,
el gran compositor, ¿verdad?
Ellos cuentan incluso, la cantidad
de [inaudible] que tuvieron que
hacer para conseguir un piano,
para que pudiera seguir trabajando.
Él también era músico,
Bowles era músico, ¿no?
Y había escrito muchas obras y tal,
sobre todo música para Broadway.
Y él se-- Al llegar a Tánger,
se dio cuenta o sintió que
él pertenecía a aquel mundo,
es curioso, lo sintió, de
una manera visceral, ¿no?
Se había casado con
Jane Bowles, ¿no?,
también una escritora
norteamericana,
y vivieron primero en la
[inaudible], la parte,
la Medina y ya después
compraron un apartamento,
dos apartamentos realmente, digamos,
en la parte moderna de Tánger,
que es donde yo iba a visitarlo.
Y era una persona extraordinaria,
una persona,
persona ya digo lacónica
si quieren,
muy inglesa, en ese sentido, ¿no?
Pero muy amable siempre, y después
tuvimos una correspondencia,
yo mantengo, guardo toda esa
correspondencia con Bowles, ¿no?
Él incluso hablaba
que le tradujera alguno,
uno de los libros creo que era.
Los otros han traducido
también al castellano,
al español casi todos, ¿no?
Y si yo tuviera que
aconsejar algo de él,
pues sería "The delicate
prey" sería, ¿no?
Es una colección de cuentos de él,
quizás el cuento sea de lo mejor,
de lo mejor-- Y realmente--
Adquirió cierta fama,
no era muy conocido, el hecho
de vivir realmente en Marruecos,
él no volvió, volvió una vez a
Estados Unidos para una operación o
dos veces quizás y ya después,
toda su vida la pasó en Tánger,
entonces, no era demasiado conocido.
Se había traducido al francés,
él hablaba, no sé, seis,
siete lenguas, Paul
Bowles, perfectamente, ¿no?
Él mismo había traducido a
Lorca, ¿verdad?, al inglés.
O sea, que conocía
muy bien la lengua,
el árabe o mejor dicho la darilla,
que es la modalidad, digamos,
no dialectal del árabe magrebí
de Marruecos, también lo dominaba.
También hizo mucho bien, sobre
todo con chicos jóvenes y tal que
tenían la facultad de
imaginar, de improvisar,
entonces él o en español
o en árabe,
los grababa y después lo traducía
y aparecían los libros, los libros,
en fin, varios-- El último que
yo conocí era, era Abdel Kader,
que era una persona digo
muy, muy interesante,
analfabeto, todos eran analfabetos.
Después dicen, yo
soy autor, yo soy--
Pero es interesante lo que hizo.
Y después también Bowles,
en los años 50, quizás 60,
para la Biblioteca del Congreso,
pues seguramente estarán aquí,
una serie de grabaciones que hizo
por las montañas sobre todo del
rifo, el norte de Marruecos y
el sur también creo que fue,
grabando la música, una música
que básicamente se ha perdido ya.
Eso lo hizo para la
Biblioteca del Congreso,
así que eso tiene que estar
aquí, esas grabaciones,
en unas dificultades
enormes, pues claro,
imagínense en las
[inaudible], aquellas perdidas.
A él le interesaba
mucho esa música,
esa música a veces de las
cofradías, los brotherhoods,
las cofradías, que también
se han ido perdiendo,
nada más que quedan una o dos,
de danzarines y de músicos.
En fin, todo eso está
recogido en el libro, ¿no?,
recordando un poco
las visitas y tal.
Después, hay algunos cuentos que
llevan también una fotografía.
Desgraciadamente, el papel para
la reproducción fotográfica,
sobre todo en blanco y
negro, eso no es lo ideal.
Es decir, que, en un blanco y negro,
aunque no es un libro de fotos,
pero en blanco y negro,
es muy poroso,
entonces se pierden todas las gamas
de grises, son básicamente diez,
según Ansel Adams, ¿no?
Diez. Eso obviamente no está aquí.
Pero bueno, yo creo que
da un poquito la idea,
un poquito la idea de que
efectivamente la fotografía no
trata de dialogar con el texto,
no es que sea ancilar, no ilustra,
por lo menos yo trato de que no
haya, evitar esa idea de ilustrar.
Y claro, aquí se crea siempre
un diálogo, por decirlo así,
a veces incluso la fotografía
subvierte un poco lo que dice el
texto o lo contrario.
La fotografía, en general,
yo he intentado hacer algo que
quizás no se ha hecho mucho en la
literatura hispánica, utilizar
la fotografía el propio autor,
sus propias fotografías.
En Estados Unidos, bueno, ha
habido algunos, por ejemplo,
Wight Morris, de Nebraska.
Él era un gran fotógrafo
y además un gran novelista.
Pero después, bueno,
Francia Breton con Nadia,
pero tampoco son sus
fotografías, o sea,
que es realmente algo que
quizás pueda todavía dar,
dar mucho, no sé.
Ya veremos, ¿no?
Y después claro, hay también
un par de textos, entonces,
yo les leeré algo, lo
que ustedes quieran.
Un par de textos de viajes, que son
crónicas, ¿verdad?, son crónicas.
Cuando viajo, claro, voy
tomando siempre notas.
En uno acá aparece, que es una
crónica toledana, de Toledo,
fue una de las visitas, de tantas
visitas que he hecho a Toledo,
claro está, y en esa
ocasión éramos un grupo,
digamos, de profesores.
Y nos pusieron a una guía
que se llamaba Almudena,
aparece también aquí Almudena.
Y esta señora pues
era estupenda, ¿no?,
lo que pasa es que yo iba
grabando lo que ella iba diciendo.
Después transcribí lo que ella nos
contó de Toledo y lo que hice es un
poco-- Una especie de voz
en off, entre paréntesis,
que era mi pensamiento o mi
respuesta digamos a lo que nos iba
diciendo ella.
Poco en plan con compadre, iba a
decir, plan amistoso si quieren,
riéndome un poco también, porque a
veces la señora se pasaba de fina,
¿verdad?
Entonces, a mí esa cosa
me hace muchísima gracia,
porque ella siempre se
refería a los profesores,
ustedes, los profesores y tal.
Y nosotros íbamos ahí
calladitos en el autobús,
escuchando lo que nos decía
la señora y yo mientras pues
iba grabando.
El magnetófono es también una
buena herramienta, ¿verdad?,
que han utilizado muchísimos
escritores.
Recuerdo ahora, por
ejemplo, a William Burroughs,
es uno de los escritores
que más admiro, ¿no?
Burroughs utilizaba
muchísimo la grabación,
imagínense lo que haría hoy
William Burroughs con la cantidad de
programas extraordinarios
que tenemos,
después para manejar el texto.
En fin. Bueno, eso es
más o menos el libro.
En la primera parte, el acantáceo
[fonéticamente] benevolencia,
ese que yo llamo, ¿no?, si
quieren se los puedo leer, porque--
Bueno, es obviamente
autobiográfico,
todo es autobiográfico,
de una manera u otra.
Y de influencia, por supuesto,
todo lo que uno ha leído y
todo lo que uno ha sentido,
y todo lo que uno ha visto y
todo lo que uno ha oído, ¿no?
Todo eso está ahí, ¿no?,
y después en esa especie de cedazo
digamos que lleva uno adentro,
va eligiendo lo que más le
interese para escribir el texto.
Me interesa desde luego mucho,
y eso ya algunos que lo han
leído en seguida me lo dicen,
es que es un libro difícil,
en el sentido de que es una
prosa muy cuidada, ¿verdad?
Obviamente, a mí no me
interesa la literatura light,
escribir novelas de
consumo, pues está muy bien,
pero a mí personalmente no
me interesa, sencillamente.
Quizás, no sé, a lo mejor algún
día me da por hacer algo así.
Pero desde luego, para mí la
palabra es todo, la lengua es todo,
en este caso y lo que trato,
trabajándola mucho usted,
como un orfebre casi, que se ajuste
realmente a mi pensamiento y a
mi sentir.
La primera lleva un epígrafe de
Baudelaire, de "Las flores del mal",
Les Fleurs du mal, dice--
[ Francés ]
>> Gerardo Piña-Rosales:
Para encontrar lo nuevo.
O sea, mediado de los años 60,
a la sazón bachiller [inaudible]
en la ciudad de Tánger,
me arrojé con el ímpetu y la
osadía propios de la adolescencia,
en brazos de las literarias musas.
Estas, sin duda, impresionadas
ante mi firme irrevocable vocación
escrituraria y tal vez
azuzadas por un tal [inaudible],
perito en criptografías,
aviniéronse a inspirarme,
ignoro aún si para mi suerte
o desgracia, mi primera obra,
un novelón policíaco de lo más
negro y más rullero que ubiqué.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Gerardo Piña-Rosales:
Internacional de los 40,
cordopolita [fonéticamente],
babélica, decadente.
Huelga decir que no me atreví
jamás a publicar semejante
paparrucha y que solo los cuatro
o cinco amigos de entonces,
supieron de su existencia,
al leerles yo en algún sororidad
tugurio de la casba los pasajes más
truculentos y escabrosos
del [inaudible] folletón.
De por aquellos años y bajo
el conjuro de [inaudible],
es otro de los míos, es parte de
mi familia, tuve una familia enorme,
y [inaudible] es parte
de esa familia,
de esa afinidad que tenemos los
escritores no, unos con otros,
data mi iniciación en
los arcanos de la poesía.
El cuerpo del delito de mi
nuevo desatino fue la sentida y
[inaudible] "Oda a Farid al-Atrash",
que compuse de un tirón una
noche de plenilunio y cuyos versos
declamé a voz en cuello,
al amanecer de un claro día desde
el mirador de la [inaudible],
frente a las costas
oscuras de España.
Si mal no recuerdo,
el grandilocuente decía más o
menos así: "Despertad, despertad,
durmientes y escuchad la dulce, el
dulce cantar de Farid al-Atrash,
los bordoneos de su plectro de ave,
cuando los chacales se
sacien de sangre negra,
cuando el gavilán desdeñe
a la trémula paloma,
cuando la acacia solitaria rompa
la monótona horizontalidad de la
pradera, renaceremos tú y yo
para soñar frente al estrecho,
donde dos mares se
hermanan y confunden.
Despertad, despertad, durmientes
y escuchad los hondos quejidos de
Farid al-Atrash".
En aquella memorable ocasión,
mi auditorio concisió del coro de
gatos, de toda condición y pelaje,
de silenciosos y soñadores,
solían merodear por entre
los agaves y las chumberas,
la albahaca y la yerba buena del
legendario cafetín colgante.
Durante mis años universitarios,
en Granada,
mi interés por la escritura
languideció un tantico.
Acaba de descubrir [inaudible] las
sabías enseñanzas del raya yoga y
el no menos sabio vinito
de albuñol.
No fue hasta algún tiempo después
de haber recalado en New York y,
entre paréntesis, crisol de
culturas, chancro del mundo,
y tras un agónico período de
enconada lucha con mis demonios y
fantasmas personales, que sucumbí
de nuevo a la fiebre graforreica.
Desde ese momento y pese a los
largos hiatos de abstinencia que
imponen la docencia
y la vida familiar,
no he cesado de emborronar
cuartillas y folios en cuyos pozos
sin fondo he ido vertiendo o
vomitando vigilias y fobias más
acendradas, pálidos reflejo
de mi cosmogonía particular,
estas fabulaciones mías, sueños,
visiones [inaudible], crónicas,
apócrifas, variaciones,
viñetas, aguafuertes, retratos,
instantáneas, momentos epigámicos
y algún que otro desvaído relato,
perpetradas en la cámara oscura
de mi madriguera neoyorquina,
aspiran, ¡Oh!
Lector, quién quiera que seas,
a servirte nada más y nada menos
y aunque solo sea por unas horas de
lenitivo bálsamo o consuelo en este
diario morir que mal llamamos vida.
Bien, después, no sé,
una cosita más, ¿verdad?
Vale. Leo rápido.
Quizás una cosita
muy corta, muy corta.
La última parte son micro cuentos,
son micro relatos, con muy cortito,
con su foto, claro está.
Es ideal, realmente ese género
para utilizarlo con la fotografía.
Otros son muy largos y
no los voy a leer, ¿no?
Aquí hay otro que es "Frank
Kafka viendo llover en Macondo",
que cuenta un poco la historia de
cuando, después de haber leído la
"Metamorfosis" de Kafka, comienza
a escribir García Márquez.
Entonces todo eso está,
claro, imaginado, por supuesto.
Solamente partiendo de
ese par de datos, ¿no?
En fin. Vamos a ver.
Por ejemplo-- Perdonen un momento.
Escribes para respirar
por la herida,
en un malo intento por restañar
las cicatrices de tu diario vivir,
tras las palabras de tu tribu,
siempre acosadas por el rayo o la
galerna que brotan a borbotones de
hontanar de tus afanes,
como un cuento o un poema,
signos mistéricos, conjurantes
de tu pasado intentando, ¡Oh!
Ingenuo, amordazar la guadaña,
casi como un pequeño Dios,
parireal y caprichoso,
asechado por otros dioses,
cegado en el laberinto
de la noche sin fin,
esclavo del grito arúspice,
arúspice del sieno y los detritos,
en busca de sueños sin presagio,
sabiendo que no has de encontrar
sino los ecos siderales del vacío.
Desterrado del paraíso
desde hace siglos,
cuando decir madre era deambular
de su mano por el zoco grande,
por el zoco chico, por las
callejas sinuosas del [inaudible].
Un tiempo en que decir padre era
sentir el mar, hora plácido,
hora embravecido, a bordo de
cualquier goleta o bergante,
en pos del capitán
[inaudible] y la ballena blanca,
cómo una montaña de nieve.
Pero de eso hace mucho tiempo.
Y hoy, al borde de la sinrazón,
que también produce monstruos,
atenazado por el miedo,
cautivo del llanto y la congoja,
solo esperas el momento propicio
para clavar tus colmillos en la
palpitante yugular de esas pobres
criaturas que se arrastran por el
polvo, ansiando descifrar
las claves de tus huellas,
víctimas de tus dentelladas
sedientas,
porque su sangre es más dulce que
la miel y con su sangre te alimentas
cada día, mientras engañas con
ademán adusto y comedido tus
compinches, cuates y carnales que
te abrazan y te miman conmovidos.
Dueño de la noche, ya lo has dicho,
pues en ella te sumerges almado
destilete, tinta y cloroformo,
garrapateando en los muros
de la gran ciudad, ¡Oh!
Manzana podrida, tus
palabras malditas,
para que los niños y las
niñas se estremezcan de placer,
para precipitarte después
a tu madriguera,
entre los viejos libros
de [inaudible],
sin resignarte a la
condena de tus ancestros,
al maléfico virus que te persigue.
Pues si ayer fueron dioses,
hoy son demonios y los
conjuras como ellos te conjuran,
desde el farol en que
cuelga tu tocayo Nerval,
al manicomio donde
balbucea [inaudible],
desde las calles tortuosas por donde
ronda el judío de Praga hasta la
alcantarilla donde vomita Poe,
desde la buhardilla enfisémica del
[inaudible] hasta el cuchitril donde
el hombre invisible se entretiene
reventando ratas a balazos.
Los conjuras como ellos te
conjuran, cuando el sol, ¡Oh!
Astro maléfico, desaparece
tras el horizonte y os contáis,
dioses abatidos y humillados,
la verdad de las mentiras.
Vuestros pequeños crímenes,
vuestras vergonzantes caídas,
mientras se asienta en tu
corazón el adiós a los adioses.
Aquí, no muy lejos de las
lenguas infectas del [inaudible],
olvidado de ti mismo,
en un victorioso final
sin ventanas ni espejos,
sordo por fin a las voces
sirénidas de la mentira,
euforia y el apócrifo delirio.
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Luis Alberto Ambroggio: Vamos a
escuchar luego, entonces, el panel,
integrado por el doctor
Carlos Paldao,
que se desempeña actualmente como
vicepresidente de la Delegación de
la Academia, aquí en Washington
DC, como censor de la academia,
miembro de la Junta Directiva
y editor de la revista,
de la revista de la Academia.
Tiene una gran experiencia como
docente en muchos países de
América Latina, también como
profesional en la OEA y en otros
organismos internacionales.
Cursó estudios de pedagogía
y literatura en Argentina,
pero se sacó un doctorado aquí en
la Universidad de George Washington,
es un resumen muy breve.
Y la doctora Carmen Benito Vessels,
que es profesora de literatura
en la Universidad de Maryland,
también miembro de
nuestra Academia.
Graduada de las universidades de
Salamanca y de la Universidad de
California, en Santa Bárbara,
autora de una serie de libros y
especialista en la época del Siglo
de Oro de la literatura hispana.
Así que, con esas breves
introducciones, los dejo,
Carlos primero creo y luego
Carmen Benito Vessels.
[ Silencio ]
>> Carlos Paldao: Muchas gracias.
Señoras y señores,
colegas y amigos todos.
En primer término, permítanme
agradecer a Georgette Dorn y a la
Edición Hispánica
por esta invitación,
para compartir algunas
impresiones sobre la obra
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias",
de nuestro talentoso autor
Gerardo Piña-Rosales,
cuya labor como autor y artífice
en el mundo de las letras
hispanoamericanas, nos acaban de
presentar tanto Georgette Dorn como
Alberto Ambroggio.
No creo equivocarme al decir
que la obra que nos ocupa,
puede calificarse de singular y
singular en el sentido estrictamente
etimológico de la palabra,
porque no se parece a ninguna de
las anteriores de un escritor.
Y digo esto cuando miro,
a título de ejemplo,
sus recientes realizaciones,
como "Los académicos cuentan",
"Don Quijote en Manhattan",
por cierto,
verdadera gema de experimentación
lingüística y
"Reflexión de identidad socio
política y cultural de lo
hispánico en Estados Unidos" o bien
"Los amores y desamores
de Camila Candelaria",
la rutilante saga de una mujer que
se desenvuelve en un contexto donde
busca insertarse para
crecer, madurar y realizarse,
a pesar de un entorno
donde lo social, cultural,
político y emocional, le es
adverso, por su condición,
no solo de mujer, sino
encima hispánica.
Si damos una mirada al contenido
del libro que hoy nos ocupa,
veremos que está organizado
en tres secciones que ya nos
aludió Gerardo.
La primera, "Recuerdos
y olvidos de Granada",
con seis viñetas granadinas.
Le sigue "Breve bestiario personal",
con cinco inquietantes narraciones.
Y la tercera y última,
la más extensa y la que
le da el título al libro,
integrada por 13 relatos, donde cada
uno de ellos, por mérito propio,
tiene elementos suficientes para
ser un estudio monográfico.
La estructura de este
libro no es accidental.
A cada portada interior, le siguen
epígrafes que a modo de singladura
abren la puerta a un mundo
de universos posibles que van
progresivamente delineando
una estructura fractal.
Cuando nos asomamos a ese universo
interior, encontramos en su lectura,
esa característica singular que
antes aludí es que el estilo de
Piña-Rosales es, de una
manera muy sutil, único,
quizás porque combina
elementos tan dispares,
como una vasta cultura y un
profundo conocimiento de mecanismo
sicológico, junto al
avanzado dominio del lenguaje,
lo que le permite manejar
los más diversos personajes,
caracteres, situaciones y entornos.
Otra característica [inaudible] de
un fino manejo del humor que podría
recordarnos a algunos de los mejores
exponentes de las literaturas
hispánicas, pero donde a veces el
tono jovial o irónico se torna en
colores oscuros para enfrentar
circunstancias propias de los
infortunios humanos.
Las voces narrativas, por momentos
las de un espectador de situaciones
que dejan entrever
dramas o hechos atroces,
que se vuelven a menudo
tragicómico;
en otros relatos es la voz del
personaje que se enfrenta con
situaciones propias de las
complejidades de las emociones
humanas, enfrentadas a esas
situaciones que nos enseñara
[inaudible], las situaciones
límites.
El tiempo para esta intervención
no me permite extenderme en comentar
varios de los relatos que
forman parte de esta obra,
pero opté para compartir uno de
mis preferidos y es el que se titula
"Confesiones de un expatriado,
mis encuentros con Paul
Bowles en Tánger",
que Gerardo también nos
dio algunos anticipos.
Veamos brevemente, cuál es
el personaje de la vida real.
Se trata del autor
del "Cielo protector".
El "Cielo protector", esta es su
novela en su versión hispánica,
que alcanzó notoriedad inesperada,
cuando la versión
cinematográfica de esta obra,
realizada por Bernardo Bertolucci--
Bowles fue un estadounidense
expatriado,
que encontró en [inaudible] la
pasión y la violencia que marcaron
sus obras.
Alcanzaría más tarde
renombre, no solo como escritor,
sino también como compositor,
habiendo estudiado con Virgil
Thompson y Aaron Copland,
como nos recordó Gerardo.
En su trayectoria, se relacionó con
los surrealistas y participó del
movimiento beat en los 50
y el underground en los 70.
Fue apadrinado por Gertrudis Stein
y además de su amplia producción
literaria, escribió
música para obras teatrales,
nada menos de Tennessee Williams,
Jean Cocteau, Lillian Hellma;
colaborando además con Orson
Wells, John Huston o Elia Kazan.
En 1943, nada menos que Leonard
Bernstein estrenó su composición
The Wind Remains, basada en la obra
"Así que pasen cinco
años", de García Lorca.
Me detuve en esta semblanza
de Bowles,
para que podamos contextualizar
en su dimensión exacta,
el relato que hace Piña-Rosales.
El mismo se abre con un
epígrafe de Bowles que dice:
"Toda la vida es como un juego cuyas
reglas son puramente arbitrarias y
no significan nada".
El subtítulo del primer episodio
es "1955, mi llegada a Tánger" que,
a modo de pórtico, situará en
el tiempo y en el espacio los
restantes episodios.
En este introito nos encontramos
solamente con dos párrafos.
El primero, refiere la
llegada de un transbordador,
luego de una corta y ajetreada
travesía por el estrecho de
Gibraltar, donde ya
se divisa Tánger.
La voz narrativa del autor
se encarna en personaje,
a la sazón un niño que
conjeturamos de unos 7 años que,
cuando su madre le anuncia
la vista del puerto,
está más ansioso por
ver de nuevo a su padre,
a quién divisa y describe:
"En el puerto, mi padre,
rodeado de camalos y
gendarmes, parecía un sultán.
Cuando me levantó
en vilo para besarme,
sentí que acabamos de iniciar una
nueva vida en una nueva tierra,
extraña y fascinante y que aquella
tierra iba a ser desde entonces,
para siempre, parte
indesgajable de mi identidad".
Destaco de manera muy
especial la segunda oración.
Cuando dice: "Sentí que acabamos
de iniciar una nueva vida,
en una nueva tierra, extraña y
fascinante y que aquella tierra iba
a ser, desde entonces
y para siempre,
indesgajable de mi identidad".
Observemos aquí, que en
estas uniones léxicas,
nueva vida y nueva tierra, junto
con desde entonces al lado de para
siempre, más que sugerir los
componentes de un posible modelo
actancial de Greimas, son una
verdadera síntesis eidética,
como la definiría Edmund Husserl,
donde la indesgajable de mi
identidad, de manera rotunda,
la palabra indesgajable anticipa el
destino de una vida en la ficción y
en la realidad, no
solo del personaje,
sino del propio Piña-Rosales.
Este primer párrafo es una buena
muestra del estilo narrativo del
autor, que no solo se da aquí,
sino en el resto del libro,
por su claridad, concisión,
precisión y cohesión,
tanto lingüística
como conceptual,
donde no faltan pinceladas
líricas, como:
"El barco atracó en el muelle,
mientras las gaviotas colgadas de la
alcándara gigantesca de una grúa,
parecían darnos la bienvenida
con estridentes graznidos".
En esta misma línea
conceptual y de estilo narrativo,
está el segundo párrafo
de este episodio.
Luego de aludir la independencia
de Marruecos, el autor nos informa,
Tánger continuaba siendo un polo
de atracción para expatriados,
renegados y contrabandistas
y, seguidamente,
en otra muestra de
síntesis conceptual,
nos ubica el entorno y contorno
de Paul Bowles en Tánger,
en el que decidirá
quedarse allí para siempre,
ciudad que se transformaría en un
lugar de peregrinación de primeras
figuras del mundo del
arte y de las letras.
Luego del episodio situado en
1955, que acabamos de comentar,
se da un salto en el tiempo,
hacia el siguiente titulado:
"Primer encuentro,
1957, en el Zoco Grande.
Así el Padre le dice a su hijo,
musitándole, "Ese americano,
es un hombre muy importante, dicen
que ha escrito muchos libros".
Y la mirada del niño,
describe el personaje así:
"Y así estaba Bowles,
un hombre menudo,
de pelo rizoso y blanquecino,
con un mechón sobre la frente,
como un viejo tintín; vestido
con un traje de lino blanco,
corbata negra, con una espuerta
en mí mano, hablando en magrebí,
con las caleñas vendedoras
del Zoco.
A partir de esa última frase,
la voz del narrador salta y
describe el mercado; sus productos,
personajes, ambientes, logrando uno
de los tantos trazos que se dan a lo
largo de este relato, donde
la descripción realista,
transporta de pronto al lector a un
escenario donde se encuentra oliendo
las mil y una especias de los
tenderetes, las voces tangerinas,
el sol, el calor, el polvo,
los olores de las comidas
y las músicas del Magreb,
junto con una miríada
de lenguas y hablas.
Los dos siguientes episodios son:
"Segundo encuentro, otoño de 1967,
en casa del escritor tangerino
Ángel Vásquez" y el último,
"Tercer encuentro, 1970,
una fiesta la [inaudible]".
Han pasado 10 años y aquí nuestro
personaje y narrador ya es un joven,
en cada episodio, 19 y 22
años, respectivamente.
Ambos pasajes tienen
características semejantes y son de
una extensión mejor
que los anteriores.
Los comentaré conjuntamente,
por razones de tiempo.
En ambos casos, nuestro personaje
es invitado por un amigo a dos
encuentros sociales.
El primero, en un ambiente de
tertulia de un grupo reducido y
cordial, donde tiene la oportunidad
de conocer y tratar directamente a
la figura legendaria de Paul Bowles.
Y tanto el dueño de casa,
el enigmático escritor español
Ángel Vásquez y otros personajes
que aparecen, como [inaudible]
Soto y Mohamed [inaudible],
fueron personajes de la vida real
que vivieron y formaron parte del
entorno de la vida
cultural de Tánger,
a partir de la segunda
mitad del siglo pasado.
La tertulia, tertulia tiene
un desarrollo animado,
donde junto a la perceptiva
descripción de personajes,
se dan intercambios sustantivos
sobre literatura, costumbres,
hábitos, interpretaciones
tanto en torno tangerino,
como de las obras del propio Bowles.
El último episodio, tres
años después del anterior,
se da en un ámbito distinto.
Se trata de una fiesta que ofrece
la legendaria Bárbara Hutton,
también personaje real que ocupó
una residencia de veraneo durante
casi tres décadas, realizando
suntuosas fiestas y dilapidando toda
su fortuna, a la vez que realizara
obras filantrópicas con gente pobre
del mundo marroquí.
En este episodio, también Bowles
es el centro del relato en donde,
rodeado de varios hippies
norteamericanos [inaudible],
esa pinta, se dan inspiradores
diálogos sobre el entorno,
no solo del universo literario,
sino también del artístico
y sociocultural.
Me detengo aquí para no
restarle placer a los lectores,
donde como en el anterior, hay una
excelente pintura de personajes,
con diálogos y tonos y
visiones divergentes sobre la
naturaleza humana.
Como dije antes, me incliné para
elegir el que acabo de comentar,
de los muchos relatos
que integran el libro,
porque los desarrollos de
sus distintos momentos,
son una muestra de la destreza de
cómo se desarrolla un relato en
torno a una situación fuera de
lo común en líneas escuetas,
una fuerte anécdota, con idioma
acuciador, preciso y directo.
El interés dramático de la
narración de nuestro autor se
característica por la manera en que
lo sicológico no está expresado en
proceso, sino resuelto en actos,
como se evidencia en la selección
que integra este volumen.
Todo su lenguaje tiende
a lo conciso,
a lo resuelto, a lo nervioso.
De ahí surge la sensación
de movimiento,
la vitalidad plena y palpitante del
ambiente que evoca y de las personas
que anima.
Convendría apuntar todavía sobre
la necesaria brevedad de este
esbozo, una virtud de Piña-Rosales
demasiado significativa para quedar
sin mención.
Es el ajuste de su rica lengua,
que no esquiva palabra o
giro dialectal necesario,
pero que también se abriga
en su clásica envergadura.
Son aciertos insistentes
de un sistema expresivo,
lo permanente y lúcida
personalización de las que se
apartan algunas muestras en las que
es posible también la constante
dinámica del aspecto verbal.
Su verbo siempre imparte la
prosa, una desenvuelta vivacidad.
Y si no abundan las gradaciones,
la acción crece por influjo
del juego lucido de los tiempos
verbales, armoniosamente dispuestos.
Y si a veces la sintaxis parece
demorarse en el ejercicio
anafórico[inaudible], la
frecuente reproducción en
oraciones reflexivas.
La lentitud no alcanza a notarse,
porque la riqueza de los
matices la desorienta y anula.
El goce que se encuentra
en una obra literaria,
ha dicho el penetrante crítico
contemporáneo John Steiner,
está compuesta por dos sensaciones,
la de encontrar algo nuevo y la de
reconocer alguna cosa ya familiar.
La estructura reiterativa
es aburrida,
la forma enteramente nueva
sería ininteligible; acaso,
en rigor, imposible de conseguir.
Del equilibrio de ambas, surge
la virtud de lo perdurable.
Vaticinar es una aventura,
pero no parece fácil concebir que
en una historia justa y serena de
nuestros géneros literarios
hispánicos,
pueda llegar a omitirse el nombre de
Gerardo Piña-Rosales e ignorar su
despejado valor.
Y ello, por una razón que
también debe expresarse,
pocas veces se da el caso de una
identidad cabal entre la clara
personalidad artística
y la fisura de una vida.
La historia literaria enumera
indigentes casos de lo contrario y
quizás el fenómeno todavía
gravita demasiado en las letras
contemporáneas, no
así en Piña-Rosales.
La luminosidad de su prosa,
su contenida emoción,
donde todo se ofrece confiadamente,
como en el asombro de la
infancia que prolonga la vida,
ni turbada por la voz áspera,
ni por la decepción
que callan sus derrotas.
Es una visión límpida de un
ser humano, de un buen corazón,
de un lugar colmado por la paz y
una trayectoria digna de encomio,
porque al igual que todos, aunque el
mundo lo hostigue y la vida a veces
se torne cenizas o llanto, él sabe
que hay una dicha elemental que
espera como premio seguro.
Para concluir este recorrido de
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias",
nada me parece más acertado que
hacerlo con las hermosas palabras
de Shakespeare.
El lema de la obra de Gerardo
Piña-Rosales puede escribirse de
modo memorable con estas palabras:
"Escribo para demostrar que no
soy menos de lo que parezco".
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
[ Silencio ]
>> Carmen Benito Vessels:
Muchísimas gracias.
Como dirían [idioma extranjero].
Excelente la presentación.
De veras, esta oportunidad
ha sido para mí única,
porque no solamente me ha
permitido disfrutar de la lectura,
recrearme en este magnífico libro,
si no que por primera vez he podido
estudiar la prosa de Piña-Rosales.
Así que muchas gracias,
Georgette, la División Hispánica,
por supuesto, Luis Alberto y
todos los colegas de la Academia
Norteamericana de la Lengua.
Son muchísimas las posibilidades de
enfrentarse a un estudio de la obra,
la prosa de Piña-Rosales.
Yo solamente he elegido un hilo,
porque si no estaríamos aquí hasta
mañana o para sábado, quién sabe.
Este hilo se centra fundamentalmente
en lo que yo creo que es el
cervantismo de la prosa
de Gerardo Piña-Rosales.
El libro, aparentemente breve,
que hoy nos reúne aquí,
es tan complejo como la albada
Artemisia de [inaudible] y tan
brillante como aquella mujer persa
que condujo a Jerjes a la victoria
naval sobre los griegos.
La estratagema más loada de
Artemisia fue hundir uno de sus
propios barcos para hacerles pensar
a los griegos que el que ella
lideraba no era un
navío persa sino aliado,
lo cual le permitió a la
astuta estratega salir invicta.
Algunas de las narraciones
de Piña-Rosales,
que Piña-Rosales incluye en
"El Secreto de Artemisia y Otras
Historias" reflejan especularmente
la citada estrategia
de la divina persa.
"Los cinco relatos del bestiario
personal", particularmente,
"La tortuga y la rata", son textos
en los que el narrador logra la
complicidad del lector para
descubrir la belleza y el arte
dentro de escenas crueles
y nauseabundas.
Y es que la belleza y el arte de
estas narraciones estriban en la
armonía verbal, que nace a través
de la pluma de Piña-Rosales.
La España de la infancia de
Piña-Rosales no tenía jardines con
columpios, sino campanarios,
cuyas cuerdas eran un
excelente sucedáneo.
No existía la Sociedad
Protectora de Animales y a falta de
[inaudible], la caja de
lagartijas y palomas,
el corretear detrás de
perros y gatos callejeros,
el azuzar al burro del carro de la
basura y el provocar el revuelo de
los gallineros caseros,
proporcionaban un excelente
entretenimiento.
Quienes crecimos en aquel entorno
conocimos a un [inaudible] y a un
Julianín, los protagonistas
de la tortuga.
En mi barrio, estos personajes se
llamaban el Pitegas y la Gallito.
El Pitegas no acuchilló
a ninguna tortuga,
pero cazaba a las palomas
de la catedral,
le retorcía el pescuezo y las
estampaba contra los arbotantes de
la misma.
Y la Gallito, como la Chelo,
también tenía pecas.
La tortuga es uno de los relatos
más breves de esta colección,
amén por supuesto
de los micro relatos.
Pero en apenas una carilla,
Piña-Rosales descubre la infancia
de una generación a la que el
narrador se dirige
de forma epistolar,
creando una confidencialidad que
hace que el lector sea también
receptor de la carta.
Piña-Rosales, narrador infidente
al mejor estilo cervantino nos dice:
"Os encontrabais cazando
lagartijas--
", y así el lector
participa vicariamente,
como requiere la banda de Julianín,
del cruel espectáculo de
la muerte de la tortuga.
Dejo el espectáculo de la rata,
para que el lector, ustedes,
lo vivan palabra para palabra.
En él ninguna sobra, ninguna falta,
pero todas juntas asfixian al
género usted humano cuando este
merece ser asfixiado.
Me referí primero al bestiario, que
es la segunda parte de este libro,
y no a las recuerdos y olvidos
de Granada, que es la primera,
porque la Captatio
benevolentiae, el autorretrato,
mis amados condiscípulos, la
última noche de San Afrodísio,
el soliloquio del alambre y
el generalife y espejismos,
que son los relatos que
abren la colección,
suponen un sutil preludio a las
narraciones de la tercera parte,
que da título al libro.
En esta última, encontramos
la clave de la escritura de
Piña-Rosales, que se engarza con
la de Ramón Gómez de la Serna,
Pablo Neruda, Gabriela Mistral
y Frank Kafka, entre otros.
Pero Piña-Rosales menciona
solo en la [inaudible],
o al menos así creo, a otro de
los maestros de cuya obra sí
quiere acordarse.
Kafka y Gómez de la Serna son
presencias reconocibles en este
libro de Piña-Rosales,
pero Cervantes y el estilo
cervantino están omnipresentes en
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias".
Piña-Rosales, al igual que
Cervantes crea personajes,
situaciones y narradores que
nos llevan directamente al autor
del quijote.
Este nos dio el yo
universal [inaudible] y la
inolvidable Dulcinea.
Rosales nos habla con idéntica
naturalidad de un [inaudible],
de una cautivadora
doncella llamada Virginia.
Se dirige a un impertinente
lector, cambio de registro,
según convenga el relato, se
convierte en narrador infidente,
inventa adjetivos necesarios y,
como la Artemisia de Jerjes
y como el ilustre Quijano,
Piña-Rosales va contra
corriente, siempre que sus ideas,
convicciones y su apreciación
del arte así lo requieran.
Así, en la dedicatoria
a Gonzalo Santoja,
Piña-Rosales le brinda a este su
obra cual toro de luz y sombras,
en una época en la que hablar
de [inaudible] y usar el lenguaje
taurino, requieren
un buen caballista,
un [inaudible] con
todas las de la ley,
que consiga la salida a hombros
por la puerta grande y que exhibe
claramente y cito: "Su loba
esteparia oposición frente a las
condiciones, valores y
mitos de nuestra época,
vuelta al ruedo Piña-Rosales".
Pero regresando a mi punto.
Don Quijote lee y lee
y lee en su biblioteca.
Piña-Rosales dice en la
autobiografía poética de
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias",
que estas y otras historias nacieron
en su madriguera neoyorquina.
Cervantes se dirige al discreto
lector con la esperanza de que en su
novela el melancólico se mueva a
risa, el risueño la acreciente,
el simple no se enfade, el
discreto se admire de la invención,
el grave no la desprecie, ni
el prudente deje de halagarla.
Piña-Rosales nos dice
en su relato y cito,
nos dice que sus relatos
y cito: "Aspiran, ¡Oh!
Lector, quién quiera que seas, a
servirte, nada más y nada menos,
y aunque sea por unas horas, del
[inaudible] bálsamo o consuelo,
en este diario morir
que mal llamamos vida".
Los conglomerados lingüísticos,
la adjetivación innovadora,
la alusión e ilusión, los
guiños al lector, la ironía,
la supra realidad de
lo inverosímil,
la inverosimilitud de lo real, el
entrelazado del sueño y la locura,
con el empirismo de lo cotidiano,
la riqueza léxica y el diálogo con
escritores [inaudible] son rasgos
con los que identificamos la prosa
cervantina y encuentran su casa en
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias".
Varias veces en el quijote
escuchamos al caballero de la triste
figura, reprender a Sancho por
su forma de hablar, "Naturalidad,
mi querido Sancho, que
toda afectación es mala",
le dije Alonso Quijano
a su escudero,
al tiempo que hilvana su prosa,
adornada con geniales adjetivos.
Del mismo modo, en
algunos párrafos de
"El Secreto de Artemisia
y Otras Historias",
los adjetivos son un
juego policromados,
cuya precisión e ironía,
Piña-Rosales comparte
con Cervantes y quien,
al igual que el autor del quijote,
remata este tipo de frases
con una referencia a la más
fragante cotidianeidad.
Así nos dice Piña-Rosales en su
autorretrato: "Con ademán chulesco,
ajeno a la luciferina vanidad,
el caballero se ajustó los quevedos
sobre el montuoso caballete de la
[inaudible] nariz.
Se enderezó el ala
del negro chambergo,
se alisó con etílica salidilla
las [inaudible] bigotillo castaño y
[inaudible] en su capa de lana de
[inaudible], encendió la pipa".
El personaje así descrito
en esta escena,
se mueve en un entorno en el
que la lluvia tamborileaba,
el viento helado y ululante
[inaudible] los bajos raídos de
los pantalones.
Y este yo auto retratado dice
cervantinamente de sí mismo:
"Como ya era habitual en él,
nuestro personaje se sentó en
las escalinatas del templo y tras
colocar el sombrero a sus pies,
como por arte [inaudible],
sacó del [inaudible] de su capa
moruna una flamante flauta travesera
que, tras breve y delicada soba,
principió a tocar con raro
virtuosismo y arte", fin de cita.
Para demostrar que el cervantismo de
Piña-Rosales no es invención mía
y a riesgo de excederme
en las citas,
dejo que el autor hable y que sean
ustedes quiénes juzguen sobre el
cervantismo que defiendo aquí
se hace patente en el cambio de
registros y enumeración de
la dieta del autorretrato.
A media tarde nuestro héroe,
que gracias a la [inaudible]
de sus fieles melómanas,
había recolectado yo un
considerable montoncete de
curruscantes monedas cobrizas,
enfundó la flauta y desdeñando
los calurosos aplausos y encendidos
piropos de su emberracado auditorio,
se dirigió una vez
más a la sabanilla,
con el solo y exclusivo propósito
de reiniciar allí su sacrosanto
rito personal del pan y el vino,
del chorizo y los pepinillos.
El tríptico del montañero
solitario, otro de los cuentos,
incluye a sí mismo un ejemplo
extraordinario de la clara extirpe
adjetival cervantina.
Aquí los dobletes y participio
sustantivados se enhebran
mágicamente unos a otros y cito:
"El montañero reservó la pipa y
contempló extasiado el rutilante
azul del cielo, roturado por
[inaudible] blanquecinas,
admiró la grácil
elegancia de los helechos,
como verdes falanges puntiagudas.
Eclosión de arcos
y lanzas en ristre,
humilde vestigio de aquellos
helechos precámbricos,
desmesurados, como los
mismos dinosaurios".
El léxico es para Piña-Rosales
como lo fue para Cervantes un campo
feraz, en lo que tanto
dice por lo que enuncia,
como por lo que irónicamente
calla o cómicamente sugiere.
Así, en mis amados condiscípulos,
encontramos una crítica
al arribismo,
en el que me parece que se escucha
el eco de las conversaciones entre
[inaudible] en su maravilloso
coloquio.
Los dos locuaces perros no perros,
en una decena de páginas
pasan un fino peine,
a estamentos sociales que se
asfixian en su propio soporte y
Piña-Rosales hace lo mismo, pero en
un solo párrafo que termina así:
"Hoy día, mis amados
condiscípulos,
abocados a la inexorable calvicie
y al bien ganado abarrigamiento,
sostienen en sus manos
garras o pezuñas,
como triunfantes escalafoneros
que son,
las riendas del poder y el
destino de la madre patria".
No [inaudible] los nombres
corresponden a las cosas y las cosas
se identifican con sus nombres.
Don Quijote cambia de nombre
según la aventura lo requiera.
Alonso Quijano, Don Quijote de La
Mancha, el caballero de los Leones,
el caballero de la triste figura.
Igualmente, el nombre del fraile
y el título de su aventura,
la última noche de San
Afrodísio de Piña-Rosales,
nos llevan de nuevo a Cervantes.
Esta vez no es [inaudible] ni son
los otros cronistas de los canales
de La Mancha, son las crónicas
de la Guerra Civil Española,
las que cuentan lo inenarrable.
Pero lo excepcional
es que Piña-Rosales,
quien ha leído estas
crónicas junto al narrador,
no llama mentirosos a los
cronistas e historiadores,
pero recurre al tópico medieval
que tan bien conocía Cervantes,
me refiero a aquella famosa frase,
esto no lo dice la historia.
Por tanto, usted, discreto
lector, ha de creerme.
En "La última noche de San
Afrodísio" esto nos dice el autor
de aquel fraile que pareciera haber
vivido en la época de [inaudible],
es más, podría haber sido
compañero de oficio del fraile
fornicario de don Gonzalo.
Y cito: "Lo que sucedería al
[inaudible] e irredimible San
Afrodísio, pecador y mártir,
frente a un puñado de mosquetones
[inaudible] no lo consignan las
mencionadas crónicas, pero si
invocarais Dios vuestro señor,
no os sería difícil adivinarlo".
Las fotos de Piña-Rosales
contribuyen igualmente a crear otros
de los recursos predilectos
de Cervantes, la polifonía.
Amén de ser magistrales,
todas ellas cumplen la función
de una narración que es a veces
paralela, a veces complementaria
y siempre enriquecedora.
Afecta a la intelección
y nos lleva a la pintura,
a veces incluso a las pinturas
negras y a sin razón goyesca.
Si hay locura en Don Quijote o si
sus ideales son tan altos que eso es
por lo que debemos
considerarlo loco,
es un tema que se viene debatiendo
desde la publicación del Examen de
ingenios de Juan Huarte de San Juan,
coetáneo de Cervantes; sin embargo,
nadie pone en duda que Don
Quijote es un loco de amor,
detalle que Piña-Rosales lleva
a su extremo en "Infolepsia",
donde el personaje central vive
en una realidad cotidiana tan
verosímil, que incluso sabemos
la marca de su coche, un Volvo,
su profesión y la beca ganada,
tenemos las fotos de su calle,
de su casa, de la iglesia que están
en las proximidades de la misma,
del ataúd donde yace
doncella, enterrada en vida.
Tenemos incluso fotos de
la doncella amortizada,
amordazada y con ojos de espanto.
La secuencia temporal es
impecablemente verosímil y también
la posible locura del personaje,
a quien su universidad le concederá
un sabático para que se recupere de
su trauma.
El modo como Piña-Rosales pasa de
un plano real a otro supera real
sigue en la más marcada
vena cervantina.
El gorroso límite entre el
sueño, el idealismo y la locura.
Así, el protagonista de
"Infolepsia" nos dice que lo
que di, se me antojó un sueño.
Y a partir de ahí, cruzamos al
umbral que raya en la locura para
todos, excepto para el
enamorado lexicógrafo, quien,
sirviéndose de sus propias uñas,
intenta desenterrar a su Virginia
en un desolado terreno en el que,
por mágico artificio,
han desaparecido la
iglesia y el cementerio.
Quizás fueron los mágicos
encantadores del quijote.
Y solo los empleados del
psiquiátrico cuentan cuenta del
protagonista, quien cito: "Desde el
ventanuco de su celda se resigna a
decir, ¿cuándo, cuándo se
convencerán de que no estoy loco,
sino solo enamorado?".
Piña-Rosales transporta al lector
en el tiempo y en el espacio,
con la misma supera realidad que
enmarca el vuelo de Clavileño en el
Palacio de los Duques Cervantes.
Muchos de los hechos que
Piña-Rosales cuenta son reales,
los personajes parece que también,
pero bien pudieron
ser o no ser ciertos.
No importa, ahí estamos, dialogando
con ellos, sentados con ellos,
bebiendo con ellos y una vez más,
lo mismo que Cipión y Berganza,
se fueron hablando por el
Colón, nunca sabremos sobre qué,
Piña-Rosales deja finales
abiertos a la imaginación,
como es el caso del
"Encuentro con Paul Bowles".
Voy a saltar unas cuantas cosas,
porque creo que es más importante
escuchar al autor que a mí.
[ríe]. Y es que el autor
Piña-Rosales cruza océanos,
lenguas y fronteras, crea espacios
polifónicos, exóticos, chocantes,
magnificentes a través del
léxico y de las fotografías.
En ellas la imagen se hace verbo
y la palabra adquiere cuerpo.
En "El paseo con Ramón
por las calles de Madrid",
la exquisita complementariedad de
imagen y palabra es mágica y es que
Piña-Rosales nos permite situarnos
con él detrás de la cámara foto
gráfica y verificar y cito:
"Que todo se transforma.
Si sabemos observar
sin ser observados".
Algunas de las fotos de este relato
son tan surrealistas como el relato
mismo; sin embargo, el diálogo que
se establece entre el texto y la
imagen, sigue una lógica
cervantina,
y vamos armónicamente
de uno a otro.
Un gato blanco [inaudible]
de una ventana,
compagina perfectamente
con una muñeca decapitada,
el retrato de la joven tuerta,
la imaginaría religiosa
y el guitarrista manco.
En este contexto de la
tercera parte del libro,
es más natural es que Frank Kafka
viese llover en Macondo y que
Melquiades leyese el obituario
del escritor Paez y muchos años
después, poco antes de
exhalar su último suspiro,
en aquel sanatorio cercano
a Viena, Frank Kafka,
habría de recordar aquella tarde
remota en que Melquiades lo llevó a
conocer Macondo, sonrió entonces
y supo que había alcanzado
la inmortalidad.
Sin locura, sin sanatorio
y no en Macondo,
sino en la Biblioteca del
Congreso, que viene a ser lo mismo,
creo que este libro también
llevará a Piña-Rosales a
la inmortalidad.
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov